[Music]
[Applause]
I wanted to chat with Mike Florio pro
football talk live co-host NBC football
night in America anytime Tom Brady's
name comes up it's a reason to have
Florio on I thought okay maybe Tom he's
going to be a minority owner of the Las
Vegas Raiders and then Jimmy Garoppolo
had off-season surgery and now feels
like maybe Tom's in the on Deck Circle
playing for the Raiders Mike who is owed
a pie to the face because he did say
that Tom Brady was going to go to the
49ers we're never going to let it go
Mike until you do it I need to do it I
need to do it I need to figure out how
best to do it where to get the pie
your wife can do it Mike
I think we agreed to lemon meringue
because it's particularly acidic and it
will irritate you it'll burn your face
yes it'll burn your face all right help
us understand exactly what's going on
with the Raiders
well
last week it was reported originally by
the athletic that Jimmy Garoppolo had
surgery on his foot
and
you know things move pretty fast days
become of weeks become months I'm
thinking wait a minute had that foot
injury in December did he not have
surgery then you go back and look we
didn't have surgery then wait a minute
what why didn't he have surgery then
he's having surgery in March and he had
the surgery after he signed up with the
Raiders and then I remembered
well there was a weird delay in his
press conference had everybody in the
building they sent everybody home and
the next day he acts like no big deal
nothing to see here that should be the
NFL's new slogan by the way nothing to
see here because we hear that all the
time
I got the contract on Saturday night and
I read the contract and I was stunned
lengthy addendum G for Garoppolo injury
waiver that deals with the foot they
took away his signing bonus over he was
due to make 11.25 million the moment he
signed under the contract they
negotiated before they did the physical
did the physical he failed the physical
had to go get surgery and the way the
contract's written if this surgery
doesn't work they never pay him a penny
and their fallback is Brian Hoyer and
rookie Eden O'Connell it's just a weird
situation Dan and I wonder how it was
all kept secret and why it was all kept
secret it makes no one look good
at all it makes Garoppolo look like
maybe he was hiding something it makes
the Raiders look negligent to not have
an alternative plan and that's what
brings Brady right to the front burner
because he's becoming a partial owner of
the very team that could be without a
proven quarterback when week one rolls
around okay can he play how would Brady
be eligible to play
and I've seen this from multiple
different Reports most recently
documented by the Las Vegas Review
Journal
for him to become a player if he's an
owner there has to be a unanimous vote
of all owners and that seems a little
harsh to me and I find you know isn't it
in these guys interest to have Brady on
the field the guy makes money for
everyone but I had someone explain it to
me over the weekend here's the problem
you have a guy who's in the building you
have a guy who has access to practice to
meetings to the playbooks to the game
Planes it's like having an extra guy on
the roster there's something that isn't
fair about it from a competitive
standpoint you have these guys your
emergency option and he's already up to
speed on everything it's just a matter
of putting him in a helmet and a uniform
and putting him on the field so if it's
going to take a 32-nothing vote Dan
my guess is they're going to be going to
be teams that say no no no especially in
the AFC West because the Broncos tried
to do this who compete obviously with
the Raiders they tried to do it when
they had that game during the pandemic
where they had none of their
quarterbacks available and they'd go
with receiver Kendall Hinton they had a
couple of assistant coaches they wanted
to put on the roster and the league said
no can't do it same idea it's like
having extra guys on your team because
they know what's going on so if he goes
through with this the deal's done with
Mark Davis just needs to be approved
unless he walks it back he's not going
to be able I believe to play for the
Raiders and be a minority owner of the
Raiders okay so he could not become the
minority owner a minority owner but he
could just postpone that and I mean why
not and that's the thing this is the
ultimate Hooper get off the pot moment
for Brady I mean if you're thinking
about playing pull the plug on this
ownership or delay it by a year it's an
easy fix and Dan my understanding is
simple and this is a question I asked
somebody who's in a position to to know
what Brady's up to after he had that
appearance in Miami several weeks back
and he was asked is there any chance
you're going to be the quarterback of
our local team and instead of saying
well your local team has a quarterback
or no I'm retired he said just enough
just enough to stoke interest my
understanding is he's done
but he loves being the center of
attention he loves being talked about he
loves it when his name comes up and I
I find that refreshing it's good to know
to notice like an actual human in there
somewhere that is driven by the same
Petty crap the rest of us are so that's
good but so you know so I think he loves
it but at the end of the day he's not
gonna play
Arizona Cardinals are they on the clock
for uh next year's draft
well they haven't actually and this is
potentially intriguing today he hasn't
DeAndre Hopkins hasn't officially been
released yet there's still a chance very
slim very slim but we've seen it before
where a team says hey we're releasing so
and so and then
at the very last minute there's a trade
it's done I don't think that's going to
happen but the key piece of evidence for
me
is that
the Cardinals could if they wanted to
wait until Friday to cut DeAndre Hopkins
if they wait until Friday they split the
22.6 million dollar cap charge over two
years they basically create 11.3 million
in cap space this year they're not doing
that they don't want to do that they
don't want to have that money on the
books they don't even want to be in
position where if somebody drops out of
the sky and we see veterans get cut all
the time somebody we didn't expect we
could get that guy and make our team
better well now they can say sorry we
don't have the cap space to do it
because they've deliberately pushed it
to next year they're pushing it to next
year they don't care about this year
it's not a surprise but it's a tangible
piece of evidence as to what we already
think the Cardinals are a team that
isn't going to try to compete a team
that maybe will position itself to have
the number one overall pick in the draft
and the Houston Texans first round pick
wherever they land and it feels like
they're in whether you call it
rebuilding remodeling or flat out Tang
thinking the Cardinals don't care about
this season all right uh one of the
danets has a double or nothing Pi bet
for you Mike okay yes yeah I had the
initial bet with Florio that got him the
pie with the 49ers so Florio Mike I'm
going to try to get you out of this
because I know you're protecting the
hair which I respect double or nothing
you have to tell me who the starting
quarterback week one first snap is for
both the Raiders
and the 49ers if you get both right
you're out wow wow but but if I'm wrong
I get two pies two pies
did you want to roll the dice on that
Mike
well what the hell since I've avoided
one pie I can avoid two respect so let's
go let's go even though I'm intrigued
and fascinated by the story I do think
it will be Jimmy Garoppolo for the
Raiders week one I think they'll get him
ready to go week one and I believe the
week one quarterback for the San
Francisco 49ers I'm not going to go
chalk her I'm going to make it
interesting I'm going to go ahead and
accept the pie I will say just for the
interest of entertainment that the week
one starting quarterback for the 49ers
will be Sam darnold boom
Mike Florio pro football is coming or
not yeah pro football talk live co-host
thank you Mike see you guys have a good
day yeah so there was a story where
somebody in San Francisco said that Rich
Eisen had inside information or a source
with the Niners because Rich had the
audacity to say
he could see Brock Purdy as the starter
and the Niners would then trade away
Trey Lance and I went
okay
where's The Insider information there
that that can't if Brock Purdy is
healthy ready to play
Sam darnold is going to be my backup
quarterback I would think maybe you
could recoup what you gave up
to get Trey Lance
uh seems logical to me